hey mal and Duma can you guys just say
you're sorry and hug it out already
your personal vendettas are holding up
the line and we've got a happy ending to
catch who said you weren't big or bad
enough to be in her gang so mal dumped a
bucket of slimy shrimp on your head and
called you shrimpy back when we were
kids
you guys remember she called her shrimpy
and the name that's kind of so what have
you seen who her mother is she's already
been punished enough it's time to join
forces and build a better our time
because let's face it felon beasts
totally missed the mark will the end of
descendents 3 be all butterflies and
rainbows or will the villains take over
our Don and wreak havoc
it's an Eevee K's game right now so keep
that box of Kleenex post because these
sad theories are rotten to the core
life on the aisle from what we've seen
in the films and trailers the Isle of
the loss is an awful place the king and
queen took every bruised and rotten
apple and trapped them on an island the
villains have tried to make a life for
themselves but they're underprivileged
and trapped all the villain kids on the
Isle are born into terrible
circumstances over which they have no
control
they all have to pay for their parents
crimes that is incredibly sad we hope
every V K gets the chance to a better
life at the end of descendants three
those left behind in the VK day trailer
the announcer says
but what about the rest of the kids who
are being left behind it's sad to think
that so many kids will not have access
to the same opportunities and it seems
like a recipe for disaster
those villain kids are going to be
pretty upset and getting left behind
maybe that's what Celia meant when she
said that all of our Adan will pay evil
is their only choice we know that some
villains made bad choices but kids are
not their parents right it would be so
sad and unfortunate if these kids became
as evil as their parents because they
saw no other way out their potential
would be squashed and there would be a
major threat to peace and harmony among
those on the aisle and those at our dime
babies aren't born evil
which is why every BK has the chance to
be good but being raised on an aisle of
villains is a surefire way to create an
army of P K's friendships will end celia
gave a very dark and foreboding prophecy
about events to come in descendants
three she said that friendships will be
tested some who bend so which
friendships will be the ones to break if
you look at the card that tears in half
from Celia's tarot deck it looks like
mal and Jay are on one side while Levy
and Carlos are on the other side so
these friendships are in jeopardy
then Celia shows the card of betrayal so
who betrays whom it would be terribly
sad if the ogv taegang broke up no good
parents if the first see students film
taught us anything is that mal Evy
Carlos NJ had terrible childhoods they
were raised by selfish neglectful
uncaring parents who were only focused
on revenge and getting off the isle from
what we've seen in descendants three
mouths dad is going to be very similar
it seems that he is also only concerned
with vengeance and escaping the Isle
Martin were you so arrogant to think if
you wrong us we shall not seek revenge
it's sad that all the villain parents
didn't learn anything from being
banished they could have turned their
focus on the next generation so their
children wouldn't have it as bad as they
did
unfortunately revenge sounded sweeter
than good parenting statues where
friends should be in the mystery trailer
for descendants 3 there is a very
disturbing scene mal is looking at stone
statues in the woods with total despair
in her eyes when we saw what she was
looking at our hearts sank it's all of
her friends Evy Carlos J Ben and even do
the dog have all been turned to stone
mal looks completely devastated but is
this just another vision
like the ones teen in the mouths
darkness trailer or is this the saddest
thing to ever happen to mal
seriously this is worse than her mom
became a lizard a beastly legacy do you
ever have a feeling that no matter how
hard you try you're a destined to become
just like your parents and we don't mean
the good parts we were talking about
repeating the same mistakes as they did
take Ben for instance all he wants is to
create a harmonious place where villain
kids and Arden kids coexist in peace but
in the mystery trailer it looks like Ben
is taking on a very undesirable
characteristic from his dad's side of
the family he goes full beast in the
trailer it's such a bummer considering
he has done the best not to follow in
his dad's a beastly footsteps a new rule
since the beginning of time it seems
that people have fought for the right to
rule over lands Aradhana in the Isle of
the Lost are no different so many
villains have fought for power and
control it's a tale as old as time but
one thing seems to be true in nearly
every single fairytale someone bigger
and stronger always tries to steal the
crown it seems that there are many
resentful villains who are trying to
take the crown for themselves
we know that the crown has been stolen
from the museum and we know that a great
evil will have their revenge forever so
can we really expect a happy ending when
heroes disappoint in the good to be bad
trailer they announced the highly
anticipated VK de mal EB Carlos and Jay
are collecting applications from tons of
villain kids to be accepted to our don
prep but only for vks will get accepted
now sings about how everybody wants to
be like them it's hard to watch that
without thinking that she's kind of
rubbing her freedom and all the B Ches
faces so many young villain kids would
look up to mal and her crew so what
happens when their heroes disappoint
them it's going to be a sad day for a
lot of kids when they pick the Final
Four the end of an era by far the
saddest thing that will happen with d3
is that it's the end of an era
we're pretty sure that this will be the
last ascendance film which makes us
super sad
we've watched our favorite villain kids
evolve from Wanda stealing Outsiders to
boss kids who are providing hope for so
many kids on the Isle and after this
movie ends there might not be any more
dissonance films
they skip the famous last line is this
the end of the story for good we can't
even think about it it's just so sad so
how do you think this story will end let
us know what your theories are in the
comment section below thanks for
watching the things be sure to subscribe
and give this video a big thumbs up if
you want more videos about your favorite
villain kids catch you next time
[Music]